[Music]
hey you guys it's tomes of terror once
again my book review show
just as on the past
couple of months worth of shows uh i'm
kind of concentrating on a lot of horror
mostly newer horror not always but a
newer horror that's available to read
for free on kindle unlimited just
because you know i went through the big
pile of print books that i had and i
don't really have uh you know i don't
really have the funds at the moment to
like buy another pile of books as much
as i would like to i do have some kind
of like older paperbacks and stuff like
that that i might
review at some point in the future but i
actually kind of got interested in
seeing what was available uh on kindle
unlimited particularly like newer books
like well-reviewed books and stuff like
that so i've been kind of going through
all the offerings there and finding some
some good [ __ ] including this one
now this book uh is called six rooms by
gemma amore it's pretty recent i think
it only came out in maybe like fall of
2021 now i had heard gemma amore's name
before but i had never read anything by
her she's a british author i think she's
from bristol
and i think the one the book that i've
heard the most about
was uh dear laura which i believe is a
serial killer novel if i'm not mistaken
she also did one called white pines or
some other uh ones she's written like a
lot
and she's mostly an independent author
which is good we always like to support
uh independent authors so that's really
cool i'm not sure if this book six rooms
was
independently published or if it's just
on a small press or whatever because
when i looked on amazon it said
independently published another thing
but then it had like a publisher name on
it as well so i'm not really sure but uh
again she's mostly an independent author
and i really like to support uh people
like that
now this book here uh kept getting
recommended to me and it's a haunted
house story so you know you guys know
how much i love those so i thought i
would pick this up and read it and i
will say this was actually
this was actually a really decent book i
you know i like
that she took the haunted house genre
and did something a little bit different
with it like the way that the book is
structured it's kind of struck it's kind
of hard to explain well i don't know if
it's hard to explain but uh it's kind of
structured in the sense that
it's based around like a tour of a house
and
in each room it you it sort of like
spotlights not only one of the
characters because there's a bunch of
characters but also spotlight's a
flashback of like what happened at this
house like a long time ago and it kind
of like ties in with the people that are
in there in the present so i'm not
really sure if that makes any sense but
that's kind of the way the book is
structured uh the beginning of the book
uh in the sense of describing this house
as some place that sort of like holds on
to its spirits or where where the
spirits like uh never leave kind of
remind gave me like a shirley jackson
haunting of hill house vibe like i said
the original novel not so much the
netflix series
so kind of like this house is sort of
like a repository for like all these
souls that you know once lived there or
died there and they either can't leave
or choose not to uh so it's almost kind
of like
a hungry house type of thing which i've
talked about before
a house that that needs souls to survive
you know like the overlook and the
shining or whatever so it's kind of like
that and i will say too that the first
part of the book
like when it's during the setup kind of
reminded me and i'm not the first person
to say this because i read a couple of
other reviews on goodreads that mention
this as well kind of gave me a willy
wonka and the chocolate factory kind of
vibe uh the
original role doll story as well as like
the 1970s uh you know gene wilder movie
in the sense that it's this
eccentric and
maybe possibly sinister person
uh leading all of these people like this
random people around this big again
possibly sinister
place and like shenanigans ensue
so it kind of had that kind of vibe to
it which like i said we like that i like
that kind of angle to it you don't
really read a lot of haunted house
stories that remind you of willy wonka
but like in a good way though i'm just
you know what i mean it's not wacky or
anything like that but just the setup of
it reminded me of that
so what we have uh the whole thing is
based around this sprawling estate
called the sunshire chateau
and it's somewhere like it's some remote
location in upstate new york some place
now this house which it's not even like
a house or a mansion it's like the way
that she describes it is just like this
massive like the biltmore estate or
something like that which is this
massive structure that was just kind of
built as
i guess almost kind of like a
like a paragon of like the person that
built it being like just uh just to show
off their ostentatious wealth and
everything
so this house was built i can't i think
it was like the early 1900s
by a wealthy industrialist named charles
lester uh who lived there with his wife
rose back in the old days
now
charles lester you find out through uh
you know just
some ex exposition like from some of the
people that are coming to the house and
also some flashbacks to come out later
on was uh not a nice dude as a lot of
these uh kind of robber baron type
people back then tended not to be uh you
know you can't amass that much wealth
without being a bit of a dick although
uh it kind of comes like i said it's
this is kind of a new book uh it just
came out in fall of 2021 so i don't
really want to spoil too much about it
but you do kind of find out that maybe
he didn't amass as much of his wealth as
as he liked everyone to think he did but
yeah so
but this uh house the sunshire chateau
is sort of like this monument to his
uh kind of wanting to i don't know if
you like wanted to rub it in the world's
face like how rich he is so it's like
ridiculously like over the top
ridiculously ostentatious like
everything is super expensive and it's
just kind of like everything is the best
best best of everything and in some ways
depending on
the character that's looking at it
uh some of the characters are kind of
like thinking it's like a little much or
it's a little tacky or whatever like for
example there's one room in it where
i guess the dude like decided that he
was gonna take this entire room and it
doesn't have any windows or anything and
he decided to like glaze the entire
thing like the walls with blue ceramic
glaze
so
it's just so the whole like all of the
walls are basically just like one big
ceramic tile
with no windows uh so the room like
constantly sweats you know what i mean
but it's just he wanted to do it because
he could and because nobody else had
done it before so it's that kind of
thing where it's all these kind of like
impractical crazy things so in the
present day uh you have a group of
tourists i believe there are eight of
them that come to the sunshire chateau
to tour this house now apparently
there's not too much of backstory about
this
but apparently
uh every now and then
like some tickets for tours of this
house go up for sale i'm not sure how
often it is uh but apparently when the
tickets do go on sale they go really
fast because it's really um you know
it's it's kind of like everybody wants
to get in there because it's so rare so
this group uh have gotten tickets so
they're waiting outside at the beginning
uh to go in and they kind of you know
you kind of get introduced to each of
them in turn i will say that there's not
a massive amount of character
development there are some
but some of the characters are kind of
like given short shrift a little bit um
and weirdly a lot of them
are not
really given names until later on
because it's almost kind of like
the point of view of the book it's not
just from one person it jumps around
like from character to character
depending on what's going on so
sometimes like if the character whose
point of view you're following doesn't
know what that other person's name is
they just call them something that has
to do with like their physical
appearance or
or how they talk or something like that
so like there's one guy who
has a baltimore accent so they just call
him baltimore and you know there's a
kind of a prissy guy with a
bow tie and they just call him bow tie
guy and stuff like that you find out
their names later on
but
sometimes like it's kind of hard to keep
track of all the characters because some
of them don't have names until later on
in the in the novel but i do kind of
feel like i don't know it didn't bother
me that much like i said although it did
i got like a couple of characters
confused a couple of times
but
i don't know i think ultimately this
isn't really a character study as much
it as it is
a sort of like meditation on the house
and
it
sort of working on the weaknesses of
everybody that comes in it and like
feeding on them essentially so
it's kind of more that kind of thing
like i said kind of like a hungry house
type situation
you know like hill house or like the
overlook so
i you know there is some character
development but it's not at the
forefront so i will say that now the way
this book is structured i don't think
i've ever read
another
haunted house book
that's structured exactly like this uh
as i said it's based around a tour of
this
mansion
and
it kind so it basically goes like from
room to room and so each room has its
own section of the book
and
whenever like you know you're in that
room like the blue room which was the
room i was talking about earlier that
has all the ceramic glaze on the walls
that's like the first section
and then uh you're kind of focusing on
the person
that uh you know a person that's in that
room and if they have something to do
with whatever and then it kind of like
goes and jumps around from character to
character as you go from room to room
now another thing that happens while
you're going through the book
is that
pretty much every time somebody in the
house and there's an implicit there's an
implication that the house is
kind of
either like
making the people inside go mad a little
bit or it's making them
kind of like forget their lives outside
so it's kind of
as i said it's sort of like feeding on
them like it's gonna keep them you know
what i'm saying so
so the longer people are in the house
you know some of them wander off and get
lost some of them forget
where they were how they got there
all that kind of stuff so there's all
that kind of stuff going on too so the
house is almost like a living entity
that's sort of like
you know plucking their memories out or
like playing on their weaknesses like
doing that kind of stuff so as it goes
from room to room
uh whoever the character is that's sort
of the focus of that particular room or
that focus of that particular section
normally what they will do is they will
touch something like an object in the
house
and
when they touch this thing they will
have a flashback
of something that happened a long time
ago when charles lester was still alive
uh and the horrible [ __ ] that he did
inside the house that had to do with
that object
so as i said this book is kind of new so
i don't really want to spoil too much
about it
but that's kind of how it goes so you
have the main character essentially who
is just called he doesn't have a name
he's just called the tour guide uh and
you don't find out who he is until like
later on
and he is just a very he's very
imperious
and
uh he's kind of like like i said it gave
me like a willy wonka vibe or kind of
like when you're going to the honda
mansion at disney like
that kind of thing like a combination of
those two things that's who i was
picturing so he's very
he seems very protective of the house in
the sense that if you insult something
about the house
or you do something you're not supposed
to do he gets very very uh annoyed about
it like for example two of the people on
the tour who don't even get to go on the
tour actually and this happens like near
the beginning of the book but two of the
uh women in the group are these like two
old kind of like
like crotchety old bitties
and when they go in the house
the first thing the tour guide tells
them is you know you have to take your
shoes off and put you know we have all
these slippers provided for you because
the floors are marble and they're like
super expensive and we don't want your
ass like scuffing them all up and
everything and these two little old
ladies just have a [ __ ] mutiny over
taking their goddamn shoes off and they
just will not do it and so there's this
big argument happens and then finally
the the tour guide like loses the [ __ ]
and tells him to [ __ ] off and you know
so they leave but then like the rest of
the tour proceeds but so every time you
you know every time you do something if
you think something is ugly in the house
like the tour guide gets really really
offended about it and all this other
stuff so i mean pretty much
so it's kind of implied at first i guess
i can say this isn't really a spoiler
it's kind of implied at first that the
tour guide
is actually the ghost of charles lester
they hint that uh just because there's
portraits of charles lester who built
the house the industrialist all over the
place because he was like
he because he was like a raging
narcissist
uh you know so they they kind of play up
the resemblance between charles lester
and the tour guide uh even though
i will say too that a lot some of the
characters that you meet
in
during the course of the tour are dead
but
they don't really
it's interesting because some of the
ghosts are just kind of like regular ass
people and then some of the ghosts are
very very clearly ghosts like for
example with like in the first section
which is based around the blue room like
the ceramic glaze room it's actually the
character that we're focusing on is not
one of the tour group it's actually a
guy named ned
who
works in the house like he's uh
cataloging all the books like from the
library
and he talks about uh how he's been
working there and how he started seeing
what was very clearly a ghost because it
looked you know it was this woman and
she was like hanging in midair and her
face was all [ __ ] up and and
everything like that so he's been he
kind of talked about that and how he
almost kind of got used to seeing it and
he ends up meeting another woman who
ostensibly uh works in the house as well
like a maid
and they kind of talk about like all the
ghosts in the house and all that
so as i said
this is kind of like the structure of
this was like really really interesting
i kind of really got into
uh them just going from like room to
room and i really liked the way that the
information like uh about the flashback
like what happened uh back in the old
days with charles lester
i liked the way that was
flashed back to i like the way that was
presented uh just basically by somebody
touching something in a room like
touching a cane or touching uh you know
a doorstop or something like that and it
would kind of go back in time and tell
you so i like that it sort of like just
gave you these little bits of
information about what had happened in
this house all those years ago like why
this house is so haunted it's not real
clear whether
this house was haunted from the
beginning if it was a thing like uh you
know lake hill house or maybe like the
overlook where it seemed like
even before the structure was built
there like this part of the i don't know
this this area of land was like some
kind of vortex or i don't know but uh i
so i don't really know if the house was
kind of like evil from the beginning
and uh you know was kind of swallowing
up all these people i don't even know if
i'd call the house eve but i guess it
kind of is but uh i don't know if it was
that or if it was just like the bad [ __ ]
that happened that charles lester did in
the house that kind of caused the house
to become that but in the end it doesn't
really matter i guess like what the
thing was because like there's a not
like i said there's not a lot of
backstory there's there's backstory
about
the [ __ ] that happened that charles
lester did like back in the house in the
early 20th century there's stuff about
that there's stuff about his wife rose
and there's stuff about why certain
ghosts are still there
and
that's pretty much it and like i said so
it's kind of going back and forth from
the present day to the past in the
present they do some kind of background
on some of the characters like there's
this one family that comes there like
wife husband uh kit and they have like a
teenage son named noah who's kind of
like your typical teenage boy like
everything's still
and he's like going around with his
[ __ ] headphones on or whatever so it
kind of goes it goes pretty much
i think pretty much her
and ned the guy who works in the house i
kind of feel like they got the most
significant backstories the rest of them
not so much the rest of them were kind
of like a little bit
you know they had like their little
scenes
but
they didn't really like get as much
depth as those two did but you know i
didn't really have too much of a problem
with that so i will say that it did seem
a little bit
i don't really know if
there was any relation necessarily or
any link between
the people that came to the house
like on the tour
and the stuff that had happened there a
long time ago like what i'm trying to
say is i don't know i don't know if it
was like a willy wonka situation where
willy wonka like organized it
magically or whatever for specific
kids like to come to the you know to
come to the factory i don't know if the
house engineers it somehow
that specific people
come to the house so that he can so that
the house can feed on their energy
because it just seems like kind of a
random thing and like i said i'm not
sure
how often this happens because they did
bring up like when they were waiting to
go into the house one of them did bring
up you know oh it's really really hard
to get tickets you know for this to tour
this house because it's like it never
happens and you know when they come up
they always like sell out right away
so i don't know if if the house is kind
of like an entity in itself that's
trying that's like putting out feelers
and then like trying to bring in certain
types of people because it did seem to
it did seem to react to different people
depending on what they were like like if
the person was a [ __ ]
then it almost seemed like the house
wanted to absorb them more but then if
they if the person was a good person
that they still wanted them but they
you know the outcome was different i
guess i'll put that put it that way like
i said i'm trying not to spoil it it's
like hard not to it's like you know i
don't know it's kind of like
this seems like a kind of book where
it doesn't really i don't know if i
would have saved it doesn't matter if
you spoil it because it's kind of
structured
not really in a traditional
three act sort of way it's kind of more
i mean i don't know that's it is but
it's kind of like more episodic
but it does have like a through line of
you know the the tragedy that happened
you know the back in the old days with
charles lester and his wife and
everything so it does have that like
kind of going through the timeline but
as far as the other stuff goes it's kind
of like just this sort of piecemeal
all these characters and they're kind of
like own story and them discovering
certain things about the house and
thinking certain things about themselves
and then them having an outcome in the
house you know it's it's kind of like
that so it's really kind of a hard book
to describe i don't really think i've
read anything quite like this before
there were a couple things that
i mean i didn't at no point was i kind
of like oh come on or anything like that
i mean i really enjoyed it even though
as i said it's not exactly like a
traditional narrative structure it's
kind of more like a series of episodes
kind of but like with a plot through
line uh having to do with the flashbacks
but i mean overall this was a pretty
pretty solid uh haunted house book like
i said it's one that had a real original
take and i that's very very hard to do
even though i love haunted house stories
even
even just uh you know plain jane
traditional ones i'm just really into it
if it's executed well but this one like
did something kind of different with the
genre and i really appreciated that i
thought it was really good you know very
well written there were a couple of i
guess because it's independently
published there were a couple of
little grammatical errors in there that
not a lot i mean i've i've read a lot of
independently published stuff and you
know most of most of the stuff is
uh some people really need some editors
this one was not bad at all i think
there was only like two or three kind of
things but one that did stick out to me
i just thought i'd bring this up i can't
remember what page it was on but she
used the word
t-a-u-g-h-t taught when she meant to use
t-a-u-t taught as in something stretched
tight uh so that was just something that
like popped out to me because i was like
oh that's the wrong word you use like
synonym there but you know i'm not gonna
get like two out of there was a couple
like that where like she used the
synonym instead of instead of the actual
word but you know as far as
independently published go those as i've
seen like way way worse there was really
only two or three instances where i was
just kind of like oh that's not right
but you know i'm kind of like a grammar
nazi as you guys know so i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get like i'm gonna mention it
i'm just gonna say but overall uh very
well written i will definitely be
reading some more of her stuff as i said
uh dear laura seems to be the one that a
lot of people talk about and
uh so i was reading like on goodreads
like some other people that have read
some other stuff of hers and said
that uh dear laura was probably the one
if you hadn't read anything of hers that
was a good one to start with so i might
get around to that one at some point as
well but yeah this is a totally decent
like haunted house if you want like a
haunted house
you know haunting of hill house meets
willy wonka type that sounds bizarre but
like i said it's not wacky or anything
like that it's not funny necessarily it
has like some humor in it but it's not
like a good like comedic you know what i
mean but it just has that kind of vibe
where it's just kind of like this
sinister figure like leading someone
around this house and like i said it
kind of gave me like a disney haunted
mansion
vibe slightly uh to it too just in the
sense of somebody being toured around
and then like all this
horrible stuff happening in like more
and more of the past being revealed as
they go to each room like as you go
through each section so i thought that
was like a really cool structure uh but
yeah if you've read anything else by
gemma moore or if you've read this one
and you know you want to tell me what
you thought about it then uh let me know
in the comments and that will do it for
this tomes of terror i will see you guys
on the next one
bye